bonjour bonjour je me permets de faire
un trop parce qu'aujourd'hui on a trouvé
une boîte une boîte très très rare
qu'une boîte qui n'a jamais été résolu
enfin si je pense qu'elle était résolu
une fois mais sur youtube personne ne
l'a jamais fait cette boîte ça a été
fabriqué par un certain constantin on
commence à le connaître ce qu'on sente 1
et constantin il a fabriqué cette boîte
il a dit cette boîte ses difficultés sur
10 parfois il ya difficulté 4 sur 4 6
sur 6 tellement elle est dure il a dit
10 sur 10 même mr puzzle il a vu ça il a
fait ça dix sur dix nouveaux barèmes
cette boîte elle est tellement rare
qu'on la trouve plus nulle part à part
sur un solide casse tête est encore
chaud qu'il reste encore une deux et on
n'est pas sûr dans le milieu très fermé
du casse-tête se dit que ces trois
mouvements pour la résoudre et 300
mouvements moi je me suis dit qu'une
seule personne qui peut résoudre 300
mouvements un mec qu'on appellerait
fabien post-it marcheurs
aller un peu vite masters le truc c'est
une incantation quoi c'est fabien tu
sors d'un casse tête j'avais demandé à
l'époque ce que l'intérieur soit creux
donc je fais un petit appartement comme
harry potter c'est plus grand à
l'intérieur on exactement tu as bien oui
ce que je te propose ouais c'est de la
résoudre diaries c'est bien on va faire
du coup c'est la partie c
peut-être en deux parties un roger
aujourd'hui l'âge et attendez j'ai deux
heures pour tourner parce qu'après je
pars un prix par donc ça résoudra 1 300
mo minimum en deux heures
c'est que si je chaloupe quelques c'est
pas bon signe j'ai compris ouais on se
la faire enfin surtout toi moi je vais
aller chaloupe et derrière la caméra à
l'échelle où tu pensais pas à
l'intérieur des dix plaies avant de
commencer laissez-moi vous indiquer que
cette vidéo est sponsorisé par dix plats
et et c'est pas le premier partenariat
avec eux les plus attentifs d'entre vous
savent qu'il ya plusieurs posters en
métal de leurs collections dans nos
bureaux despite propose un large choix
de visuels avec à la fois des design
deux marques mais aussi des design
artistique des licences donc n'hésitez
pas à les découvrir leur site si ce
genre de déco vous plaît parce que
demain si ça vous plaît pas c'est pas la
peine mais sincèrement je pense qu'il
est impossible de ne pas trouver au
moins un poster qui vous plaisent sur
toutes les galeries qui propose pas ce
moment par exemple ils ont même des
visuels de marvel docteur strange ils
sont toujours là en plus la livraison se
fait en quatre jours en moyenne sais pas
si c'est passé c'est pas neuve c'est pas
12 c4 c'est pour ça que j'ai dit 4 en
moyenne c'est ce qu'on appelle quelque
chose de très rapide pour ce genre
d'achat le gros point positif des
posters despite c'est leur système de
montage par heymans est vraiment ultra
simple et ça permet de changer de mood
dès que la vie nous en prend autant vous
dire qu'ici on en change souvent grâce à
ça parce que on en met au mur il n'y a
pas que loïc qui se promènent avec des
dix plaies du matin au soir
displayed c'est en fait une bonne
alternative aux impressions standard sur
papier ou sur toile c'est aussi moins
cher grâce à la réduction qui est
disponible en utilisant le lien dans la
description celle de cuba celle de moi
si vous passez par ce biais en
description vous allez bénéficier
d'autres réductions tout grosse erreur
n'hésitez pas on hésite on hésite on
hésite ou pas loïc il va il est passé où
les bonbons n'hésite pas ok c'est parti
donc la boîte pour de vrai 1 300
mouvements minimum on a été les premiers
à la résoudre sur youtube en tout cas au
moment où tant de la vidéo on n'est pas
à l'abri que tant qu'on monte qu'on l'a
sorti une personne qui l'avait et
effectivement je n'ai vraiment que deux
heures là pour la résoudre
personnellement j'y crois pas voilà
comment elle se présente l'exploration
aller vite fait c'est pas un truc où on
doit se dire qu'il ya un endroit enlever
ou quoi je ne pense pas je sais que
toutes les boîtes avec beaucoup de
mouvements d'annoncer ce sont des boîtes
avec des choses un peu séquentielle là
il ya sept tirs est de ce côté ici
pareil là ce petit bitonio la y en a
deux on sait que ça va être des
mouvements par rapport à ça vous savez
ce que j'aime bien faire à chaque fois
c'est 2
là elle va s'ouvrir de telle manière là
j'avoue j'avoue qu'il ya tellement rien
qui bouge je suis pas capable de dire
comment elle va s'ouvrir mais ça
m'embête un peu parce que si je sais pas
comment elle va s'ouvrir je ne peux pas
essayer d'anticiper un petit peu des
choses je ne cherche pas à comprendre ça
à la elle a l'air vraiment ardue quand
même ça
c'est de la la ils sont reliés si je
bouge lui ça bouge oui je vais essayer
de le caler en même temps voilà on le
voit sur la caméra était derrière moi
les deux
fils ils se bougent en même temps sinon
on peut pas donc là pour l'instant il
était au milieu on voit ses mobiles les
historiens d'en faire pour l'instant ça
ça m'a l'air complètement fixe j'arrive
pas bougé coque ce soit lui on sent de
la mobilité lui il a l'air très fille
car celui du santal rtfx mais c'est
peut-être pour le moment là lui je peux
pas le descendre ce double la même si
j'appuie très fort je peux par contre le
monter est-ce qu'il ya plusieurs
positions entre je ne sais pas ainsi
s'achève ces questions-là jeu sam a rien
changé de le monter au départ j'ai dit
qu'il était comment il était en bas et
la moitié par exemple
à temps j'ai réussi à le descendre à il
n'était pas complètement en bas en gros
vous le voyez sur cette phase là moi
quand je l'avais là il était comme ça et
je viens juste de le descendre un petit
peu je peux pas plus bas et ça m'a
permis de tirer la forêt donc là si je
le descends je peux tirer là c'est tout
deux mouvements après si je le remonte
maintenant je peux pas de remonter plus
que ça d'accord ce que ça me permet de
faire autre chose oui je peux encore
tirer plus du coup ok maintenant j'ai
tiré plus puisque je peux faire autre
chose à dire non c'est juste que cette
mobilité là en plus si je leur descend
encore je peux encore le tir est ok si
je le remonte encore des sanglants non
ok donc j'ai eu un système d'alerté qui
m'a permis de sortir ce petit jeu là
quand même assez fort là je vais essayer
de le descendre de le monter encore plus
lâche peu ok d'accord je pense qu'il va
y avoir un système d'alerté tour dans le
truc
ça m'a donné de la mobilité dernier
mais par contre rien faire d'autre
je cherche à comprendre le
fonctionnement de la séquence que là
j'ai essayé de rentrer lui pour voir si
peut-être pas la lâcher en train de
penser aux riffs à bout très fort
pardon je me suis auto congratuler mais
ça m'a permis de sortir lui qui est
maintenant si je ressors lui
qui est holla là j'ai compris en fait là
chaque fois que je veux faire un
mouvement sur celui ci
oui je vous explique je crois que j'ai
compris le fonctionnement rapidement si
je veux faire un mouvement sur cette
tige de sortie il faut que lui soient
complètement rentré ou complètement
sortis en gros là il est rentré donc si
je fais un nouveau mouvement sur lui il
faut qu'il soit complètement sortis et
s'il était sorti pour faire mouvement
sur l'iph avec soit complètement rentré
et je pense que ça va être comme ça
d'étape en étape où à chaque fois savard
est impacté les autres
lui la théorie elle fonctionne ça va à
une vitesse incroyable
j'ai commencé il ya pas si longtemps du
coup lui maintenant pour le sortir
complètement j'imagine que pour
continuer à le sortir et leur entrée il
va falloir que lis-je leur rente mais
pour leur rentrée va falloir que ça va
maintenant que tu es lui je vais essayer
ça
donc là je leur rende ça me permet en
temps normal de bouger intrants
maintenant lui je le ressors
voilà c'est une d'ingres et c'est une
dinguerie t ça m'a permis de le bouger
d'un grand jeu leron rentrer
tact maintenant je le ressors
on en fait là du mouvement là c'est pas
mal c'est pas mal c'est pas mal ok et
lui maintenant
non ça me permet pas le nom il faut
d'abord que je le rends je pense
est donc la wii est donc et bella il
faut que je fasse wallace vache folle se
fasse le même processus maintenant de
ressortir complètement l'autre c'est
qu'il se passe est fou
est incroyable c'est aussi incroyable
que si vous vous abonniez à cette chaîne
pour soutenir ses efforts s'il vous
plaît et activer la cloche aussi tu dis
donc les recommandations et youtube se
puisque ses terres
non c'est bon ah oui mais je pense que
tout doit être sorti du coup
c'est un peu moins parler parce que là
si je parle j'ai l'impression que ça
fait des bêtises ok donc il me reste
encore toute la séquence à refaire pour
avoir celui-là c'est possible
franchement ça fait combien de temps que
je tourne ce peuple et non mais pour de
vrai
franchement je suis pas mal je crois je
crois que j'ai compris le fonctionnement
direct
c'est vrai et alors il faut
c'est incroyable alors maintenant que je
suis ici qu'est-ce que quoi alors entamé
un problème le hic je peux te
l'expliquer en gros j'ai compris toute
la séquence donc là je suis arrivé à la
dernière étape de cette séquence de
trois où je suis en train de me dire
j'ai été très excité mais vraiment vous
m'avez vu regarder
excitation très excité à comprendre
comment ces trois étaient imbriqués et à
réussir à sortir lui complètement
j'arrive à cette fin d'étape et en fait
je me souvienne de ce que j'ai dit au
tout début de cette vidéo je sais pas
comment elles s'ouvrent j'arrive pas à
comprendre et en fait je me suis créé
moi même un casse-tête ici tu vois mais
c'est à ce trou c'est pas ça du tout
fallait faire il fallait peut-être
impact et celui je ne sais pas votre
bien possible
je vais essayer de faire ça retient
regarde regarde regarde regarde la
dinguerie de ce truc tu regardes la
gelée sortie lui entièrement ça devrait
me permettre de sortir lui maintenant
pour continuer à sortir lui il fallait
que je le rentre mais maintenant il faut
que je ressorte lui pour pouvoir le
sortir et maintenant que je rentre
ainsi elle se trouve c'est une séquence
comme ça de trucs à cheval
là je vais essayer ma théorie de les
sortir tous les trois tu vois d'accord
oh oui ça me permet d'aller tout temps
mais non mais non
j'ai envie que les généraux jir il est
ouvert
regarde pour de vrai sur la caméra
complet j'ai mis au smic
si vous avez des problèmes dans votre
vie insoluble les espèces de casse tête
à résoudre dans ta vie tu m'appelles
sans postiches un point positif
en fait un vieux truc tu as fait oui
bien sûr c'est exactement ce qui s'est
passé mais je crois que les trucs un peu
exponentielle c'est mon truc quoi
personne ne s'y attaquer sur youtube
parce que personne n'a osé parce qu'il
faut 300 move minimum je te jure je
pense que j'ai j'ai dû faire peut-être
cinq mouvements inutiles donc j'ai dû
faire 305 me j'ai eu la bonne méthode du
premier coussin délire et ben voilà et
en plus tu as vu ce qu'il ya dans la
boîte évidemment merci a dit spectre
d'avoir sponsorisé cette vidéo vous
retrouverez un lien dans la description
ouvert toute cette offre incroyable
parce que je fais une voix off parce que
non c'est pas vrai j'avais pas du tout
oublié d'enregistrer son petit morceau à
la fin 1 voilà merci dispagne et
maintenant on voit si on peut discuter
en même temps qu'elle était la dette que
tu as le plus détesté sur en création
c'était une date où tu étais là
j'étais pas d'un gain même sûrement et
et hachez pas les moyens et mais celle
ci quoique or qu'est ce que tu as fais
le
l'année dernière qu'il a un an pile tu
peux t'en souvenir c'est ce qu'elle
faisait en mai c'est vrai ça
je faisais la fin de singularité il
semble pour l'instant tu préfères
singularité ou le nouveau spectacle moi
je préfère toujours le en fait c'est
comme si tu me demandais ce que je
préfère
exactement où la ou les vidéos jeux tu
vois ce que je veux dire je préfère
toujours le dernier tu vas rester à
quatre pattes comme si je suis obligé
possède ainsi remonter trop grand c'est
ça ouais rien t'as combien de plusieurs
dans sa garde-robe ah là là mais j'en ai
tellement je rêve d'un truc je rêve de
déménager en fait et d'avoir un endroit
où je peux vraiment rangé mes fringues
et au même endroit on y pressent alors m
e mois 300 mouvements jeter les faits
comme ça moi il n'y a pas de
il n'y a pas de problème en fait un mois
je peux discuter en même temps tak tak
ta vu connais beaucoup de gens qui se
souviennent que avant la chine ne
s'apaisent pas la chaîne secondaire mais
bien fabien arts au petit matin s'en
souvient je suis assez étonné de de
savoir qui s'en souvient ce qui est ce
qu est ce que vous pensez qu'il faut que
je refasse une vidéo post it un peu
comme un sac une vidéo petit mon extrait
arriver bonjour bienvenue sur la chaîne
fabien art oppose type master sur cette
chaîne je ferait apparaître des stylos
et je vais vous apprendre la technique
en fait en fonction alors là c'était pas
mal franchement c'était soigner c'était
travailler c'était novateur sur youtube
qui faisait ça regarde faire de faire
les allers 300 mouvements
allez ban à outreau les gars merci et
bien cette boîte d'une difficulté 10 sur
10 a été rondement mené rendement résolu
c'était ce que pour la performance là
qu'on était là c'est le mec c'est un
athlète c'est un athlète du k-7 je pense
que voilà c'est un sportif de haut
niveau au niveau des caisses être le mec
est arrivé pas ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta
chercher le sens de la vie de l'univers
ou pop et réponses à toutes les
questions oui c'est vrai que je m'en
occupe tu l'as dans 10minutes d'accord
merci et valérie au lit car
je pensais vraiment qu'on a les mêmes
examens on s'était dit ouais ça partir
sur deux parties tout ça c'est parti sur
une partie de dix minutes et c'est déjà
pas mal
mais c'est parce que je suis je suis je
suis choqué un peu n'hésitez pas aussi
loin dans la description le nouveau
livre de fabien pour la mémoire ouais
c'est ça à nouveau libre up en plus vous
voyez il est là voilà c'est vraiment
tout ce que j'ai à dire c'est lui c'est
vraiment lui vous avez le pouvoir donc
c'est vous qui l'avez vous allez pouvoir
d'acheter ce livre est de vous faire du
bien au cerveau merci à tous là vous
trouverez une vidéo de castets et là une
vidéo bas pour un genre et de chants
castex
que vous voulez à très bientôt ciao ça
m'a fatigué
waouh le mec la défense